Yeah,
so we started to talk a little bit about
phenomenology last time and about Carl
Rogers and uh,
I mentioned that the phenomenologists
were interested in experience in some
sense as the ultimate reality and that's
it's a very complicated concept to,
to grasp
the existentialists
also adopted that viewpoint.
They were concerned with the quality of
subjective experience,
not that they were ignoring the reality
of object of experience,
but they were concerned with the reality
of subjective experience and they're
also more focused on action then on,
on statement or belief.
Here's something to think about.
You can think about this for a very long
time.
If you're trying to understand what
someone believes,
even if you're trying to analyze their
representations of the world,
should you pay attention to how they act
or what they say.
And that's a profound question even from
a,
from a neurological perspective or a
neuropsychological perspective because
the memory system that you use to
represent what you say that you believe
is not the same memory system that you
use to embody your,
your knowledge about action.
So it's,
it's a can.
I would say to the distinction between
telling someone how to ride a bike and
knowing how to ride a bike,
those are not the same things.
The descriptions don't even really lay
very well on top of one another because
you don't actually know how you ride a
bike.
You just know how to do it.
It's built into your physiology,
right?
It's a skill,
and that's called procedural memory.
Procedural memory is the same kind of
memory that basically structures your
perceptions.
I'm not.
It's not that you can't orient your
perceptions consciously because you can,
but once you've oriented them
consciously,
say towards some goal,
it's automatic procedures that take over
because you really don't know how it is
that you organize your senses so that
you can pay attention.
You just know how to do it.
Now,
the existentialists believed that
actions spoke louder than words and that
if you were interested in belief and
even if you were interested in analyzing
belief,
that it was better for you to look at
how someone acted than what they said.
Now,
one of the things that you might think
with regards to rogers
is that his psychotherapeutic practice
would be predicated on the idea that you
should bring how you act into alignment
with what you say you believe,
so that there was no discontinuity in
your between your body.
That's one way of thinking about it and
your mind and so that there are fewer
paradoxes in your
in the way that you manifest yourself in
the world.
So the concentration on auction is one
of the fundamental characteristics of
existentialism.
Another one is
the insistence upon trouble and
suffering as an intrinsic element of
human experience.
So you could say,
we could concentrate on subjective
experience.
What's your life like to you?
How do you experience it?
And we could say,
well,
built into that is trouble built into
that is chaos built into that is anxiety
and pain and disease and and that you
can fall prey to those things without
there being something wrong with you.
Now you know if you pin down a
psychoanalyst like younger Freud,
they would of course admit that human
misery is endemic to human experience,
but Freud in particular tend to look
tended to look for adult psychopathology
in childhood,
Miss Adventure in childhood,
in pathological childhood experience,
and he at least implicitly claimed that
if you hadn't experienced childhood
trauma and you had developed properly,
that what would happen is that you would
end up healthy roughly speaking,
certainly mentally sound,
but the existentialist centrally by that
perspective,
right from the beginning,
they basically make a different claim,
which is that life is so full of
intrinsic misery,
let's say,
but suffering is a better way of
thinking about it.
Suffering that manifests itself as a
consequence of your intrinsic
vulnerability,
that psychopathology is built into the
human experience.
There's no real way of avoiding it or at
least
there's no reason to look for extra
causes.
That might be a better way of thinking
about it and
you'd be surprised how often that sort
of observation is useful for.
For clinical clients,
for example,
because one of the things that's quite
characteristic about people,
especially if they're introverted and
they don't have very many friends,
they don't have people to talk to.
If they're suffering,
maybe they're depressed or anxious or
they have some sets of strange symptoms
like agoraphobic or obsessive compulsive
disorder.
One of the things they always presume
that is that the fact that they're
suffering in that manner means that
there's something not only something
wrong with them but something uniquely
wrong with them so that it's their fault
and no one else is like them.
And one of the things you do as a
diagnostician,
you know,
you'll hear a lot of rattling about how
labeling is bad for people and certainly
mislabeling is bad for people and even
an accurate label can be a box that you
can't get out of.
But it's very,
very frequently the case that if you
diagnose someone,
it's a relief to them.
Like you can't believe because they come
in to see you knowing that something
isn't going properly,
but they think,
well,
they're the only person facing it and
that means they're idiosyncratically
strange.
In some incomprehensible way that no one
else could possibly understand and
there's no way they could ever get
better and one of the things you do is
pointed out to them as like depression
and anxiety doesn't really require any
explanation.
Right?
There's plenty of reason.
I don't remember who said it.
Everyone has sufficient justification
for suicide.
I think that was the claim well,
but the point is is that if you look
through the experiences of the typical
person,
unless they're very,
very fortunate and they won't be that
way forever,
that's certainly the case,
that they can point to traumatic
experiences in their life,
death and loss and illness and and
humiliation and all those sorts of
things that are sufficient to account
for existence in the state of quasi
permanent negative emotion.
Now,
often if you see,
as I said,
if you see people who are depressed and
anxious by nature,
they assume that everyone else is the
smiling face that you see on facebook
and so that that alienates them from
other people and themselves.
Even more than that,
then that certainly far more than
necessary,
and part of the psychoeducation that
goes along with therapy is merely
educating people to understand that a
fair bit of misery is the norm and that
there's plenty of genuine reason for it.
And so the existentialists basically
start from that stance.
Um,
it's like a fall of man stance in some
sense,
you know,
because deeply rooted in,
in,
in the western tradition,
roughly speaking is the idea that people
are divorced from some early paradise
state and that it was the emergence of
something like self consciousness that
produced that demolition of humanity and
left us in a damaged state.
And um,
I mean,
people think they don't believe that,
but they believe it all the time.
Um,
and it's frequently help people
experience themselves as,
as if there's something wrong that needs
to be rectified.
And it seems unique in some sense to
human beings.
It doesn't seem all that obvious that
animals think that way.
But people definitely think that way.
And so all the existentialists basically
take that as a given and then they,
they,
they offer another question which is,
well,
given that that's your lot and that
there's ample reason for misery,
how is it that you should conduct
yourself?
Because merely say giving into that
misery or multiplying it doesn't seem to
be.
It doesn't seem to do anything,
but multiply it.
It doesn't seem to do anything but
increase.
It knows that it's bad to begin with.
You might say,
well,
increasing it is definitely going to be
increasing in is something that you have
to regard as worse.
So how do you conduct yourself in the
face of misery?
Okay,
so how do they,
how did they present that to begin with?
Well,
this is from Pascal and and this is an
existential statement that describes the
position of the individual in the
universe.
You might say,
or,
or you could say that it explains the
individ,
the deep,
deep characteristic of individual
experience or existence.
Hence existentialism.
When I consider the brief span of my
life swallowed up in the eternity before
and behind it,
the small space that I feel or or even
see engulfed in the infinite immensity
of spaces which I know not in which no,
not me.
I am afraid and wonder to see myself
here rather than there for there's no
reason why I should be here rather than
there or now rather than then.
And so that's an element of existential
thinking that is shared with the
phenomenologists called thrownness.
And that's a term that heidegger
originated,
if I remember correctly.
And what it means is,
is it's an analysis of a certain
characteristic of human experience,
which is that,
well,
there was an immense span of time in
which you could have been born,
but you weren't born then.
You were born 20 years ago and there was
an immense span of time in the future
that you could have been born and you
weren't born then.
Either you were born when you were born
and your who you are and you have
exactly the characteristics that you
have.
And there's something tremendously
arbitrary about that.
It says,
if you were thrown into experience and
that's what thrown this means,
it means that you were randomly placed
in a place and time and there's
something fundamentally irrational about
that,
meaning that there's no real way of
understanding it.
It's something you have to deal with and
you might say,
well,
why was I born poor?
Or why was I born less attractive than I
might be?
Or,
or why was I born less intelligent than
I might be,
or maybe why I was.
Why was I born to these terrible parents
at this particular horrible moment in
time?
And in some sense there's no answer to
questions like that.
It's just how it is and you have to deal
with it.
So the question is for the
existentialists,
how do you deal with that?
This is Walter Calf Kauffman for Renault
Rollo may rarely has the existential
question we'd put more simply are
beautifully.
In this passage,
we see first the profound realization of
the contingency of human life with the
which the existentialists call
thrownness.
Second,
we see Pascal Flinch facing
unflinchingly unflinchingly.
The question of being there or more
accurately being where third,
we see the realization that you cannot
take refuge in some superficial
explanation of time and space which
Pascal scientists that he was could well
know and lastly the deep shaking anxiety
arising from this stark awareness of
existence in such a universe.
There's a
fairly well developed line of social
psychological theorizing known as terror
management theory and the basic premise
of terror management theory is that
human beings have belief systems and
what the belief systems do is serve to
protect them against death,
anxiety and that now I have that that's
derived from the work of Ernest Becker,
by the way,
who wrote a great book called the denial
of death and his theories in the denial
of death have been put to the test by
the terror management theorists with,
I would say some success,
but I think the theory is flawed because
I don't believe that
becker phrase the issue properly.
I think it's deeper than a fear of death
and that's what the existentialists are
attempting to to to communicate.
It's more like.
It's more like terror at ice.
It's more like terror of isolated being,
you know,
it's not only that you're a pro,
you're mortal,
you know that you have a border,
a temporal border,
you're born and you die,
but also that during that time you're
vulnerable to all sorts of things and
all sorts of contingencies.
One of which of course is death,
but it's by no means the only one that
is horrifying.
I think you can certainly make a case
like the existentialists do,
that.
The mere fact that you're your limited
in the face of infinite complexity is
also a primary existential problem.
It's a problem that human beings have
been dealing with ever since they
started to understand.
They started to make sense of concepts
that were beyond their immediate
experience.
No
millions of years ago or tens of
millions of years ago when our ancestors
lived in trees.
You could be sure that they were
frightened of what surrounded them.
They were frightened of when they were
little.
They were frightened of birds that might
pick them out of a tree or they were
afraid of cats that might climb a tree
and eat them.
They were afraid of snakes that would
come slithering along and bite them,
and
they were.
They existed in the space that was safe,
surrounded by a space that wasn't safe,
that was full of predatory,
a predatory entities,
and those were primarily birds of prey
and cats and snakes or other reptiles,
and then what seemed to have happened as
we evolved was that the way we construed
the world,
you can think of the world as a safe
place surrounded by the possibility of
predation,
but you could also think of the world as
the known surrounded by the unknown.
It's the same idea except put up one
level of abstraction and the unknown has
the same relationship to us in some
sense that the territory of predators
has relationship to us and we use the
same circuitry to represent the absolute
unknown that we used so many millions of
years ago to represent predators.
Now it's called more complicated for
human beings because first of all,
we're not just prey animals.
We're also predators.
And so we're not only targets,
but we're the thing that makes other
thing targets and we're also something
that isn't only shaking in the face of
the unknown because of it's predatory
element,
maybe like a rabbit,
but something that can explore the
unknown and Garner something of value as
a consequence.
And so we have this very paradoxical
wiring.
You might say that a known is partly
terror and that's the prepotent element
of the unknown.
So negative emotion for human beings is
more powerful than positive.
Emotion is sort of dose for dose and
that's I think that's because you can be
completely and utterly dead,
but you can only be so much happier and
so it makes much more sense to be tilted
to some degree towards sensitivity to
negative emotion than it does to be
tilted towards sensitivity for positive
emotion,
but it's also another one of those
things that makes life rather
intrinsically dif difficult because
negative emotions are commonplace and
they're powerful and they need to be
because otherwise you'd wander stupidly
into something that would kill you and
it's better to be anxious than to be in
pain or dead.
Even though it's not so good to be
anxious,
so for the existentialists that the
fundamental,
the fundamental quality of human
existence is limitation in the face of
incomprehensible complexity and all of
the things that stem from that
existentialism is not a comprehensive
philosophy or a way of life,
but it an endeavor to grasp reality.
Existentialism is immersed in and arises
directly out of man's anxiety,
estrangement and conflicts.
This was written 60 years ago and it was
written so it was.
It was aimed at western audiences at
that point,
if you go back 100 years,
you could make the case or or or perhaps
a little longer than that.
You could make the case that the parts
of the world that weren't western,
we're still reasonably well ensconced in
traditional belief systems and so those
traditional belief systems provided an
overarching canopy of meaning.
That's one way of thinking about it.
That was designed exactly to you could
say rationalize or you could say cope
with or deal with.
Depending on your perspective.
That existential anxiety it gave,
gave significance to everything.
It gave meaning to everything and there
was a religious systems.
Let's say,
but they came crashing down in the West
in the late 18 hundreds and then
increasingly everywhere else in the
world.
So the point at which we are now in
time,
it isn't reasonable to only consider
this a pathology of the western
individual.
It might even be the prime conflict that
exists in the world right now between
comprehensive and traditional religious
systems in a modern viewpoint that has
this existential angst built into it as
part of its as part of its nature.
Maybe it's the price you pay for
increased technological mastery and
awareness,
but it's a big price to pay and the
existentialists were concerned about
that because they also believe that
although the scientific method had given
us immense technological power,
the worldview that came along with it,
which you could say in some sense,
is incidental to the method,
but it doesn't matter.
The worldview that came along with it
was sufficiently powerful and objective
and reductive to blow gaping holes in
the meaning systems that protected us
from our existential anxiety and to open
us up to the possibility number one of
nihilism,
which is really belief and nothing,
and we'll talk about that more as we
progress or a proclivity towards
rational totalitarianism,
which would be,
you might say,
the,
uh,
extreme reaction to the threat of
nihilism and the abandonment of classic
belief systems.
I,
I think you still see that playing out
everywhere.
You certainly see it playing out in the
universities right now because the,
there's huge ideological conflicts at
the,
in the substructure of Western
intellectual thinking.
And people are,
and this is very hard on young people,
they're caught in part B,
be between an emergent nihilism that
seems to be implicit in a materialist
worldview.
And the temptation of radical
ideologies.
And neither of those options I would say
is tenable.
I mean,
the nihilistic option leaves you with
nothing.
And that's not good.
And that's an existential realization in
some sense too,
because if your life is fundamentally
problematic,
without you being pathological,
just as the the essence of your life,
then you need something to defend
yourself,
to defend against that.
You can't just have nothing because all
it does is leave you with the suffering
that's implicit in your experience.
And then to swing to a totalitarianism
totalitarian system means that you don't
even exist to.
Once you've done that,
everything you say can be predicted.
You're just the puppet of a of a
rational scheme that has an explanation
for everything.
But that's really good for nothing
except destruction because it's too
vague and abstract it to be used to
actually solve any concrete problems.
So this is,
this is the situation of modern people
as far as the existentialists were
concerned and the people that I'm
talking to you about specifically,
I'm going to talk to you about Nietzsche
and Dostoevsky and Kierkegaard and I
picked those people who aren't
psychologists,
except in the broader sense because I
don't think there is anybody who there
were and are existential
psychotherapist,
but I don't think that any of them do as
good a job of explaining the problem as
those people do.
So you might as well get right.
You might as well get the information
right from the source.
Like psychoanalysis.
Existentialism seeks to utilize these
very conflicts as avenues to the more
profound self understanding of man.
Well,
so what does that mean?
it means at least in part,
that the theorists that we're going to
talk about had an idea that was akin to
the psychoanalytic idea of facing what
you're afraid of,
and that's a key concept in
psychotherapy.
There's,
there's not that many key concepts in
psychotherapy.
One might be that you enter into an
honest relationship with your client.
The second is that exposure to the
things that you don't want to be exposed
to is curative.
If it's voluntary,
that's a big deal and it has to be
voluntary.
It can't be involuntary because that'll
just make it worse because you might
ask,
well,
you know,
if a kid has a fear of rats or mice,
they got that fear because often they
were exposed to rats or mice and then
you use exposure to rats and mice to
cure them.
Well,
that makes the precipitator of the
illness,
the carer,
which makes no sense.
Well,
what's the distinction?
it's,
it's one thing to have something pop up
at you when you're not expecting it.
That puts you in a state of of
apprehension and preparation for action
in the state of even a state of terror
estate of a reflex of shock and then
perhaps terror and maybe something you
don't recover from that's completely
different than facing something
voluntarily.
The psychophysiology isn't even the
same,
so if you're faced with a stressor of a
certain magnitude and it's involuntary,
your body produces a lot of the stress
hormone cortisol and in large doses,
cortisol is toxic,
especially if it's produced over long
periods of time,
but if you face it voluntarily,
then that doesn't happen.
You use a completely different set of
circuits to do something voluntarily and
it's the utilization of the voluntary
circuits that indicates your mastery
over the thing that you're afraid of and
that mastery over the thing that you're
afraid of and can't cope with.
That actually constitutes your adaptive
personality.
And so part of what the existentialists
were suggesting is that precisely and
you see this,
you see this in Freud with his
insistence that you go into your messy
past and dig up the corpses in the
skeletons and sort them out and young's
insistence that what you want most is to
be found where you least want to look
and Roger's insistence that people
communicate honestly about difficult
things.
It's all predicated on the same idea in
some sense that voluntary exposure is
one of the prime things that cures
people and one of the things that you
should think about,
you think,
well,
is that a valid claim?
Well,
you have the psychophysiological
evidence,
but it's also the case that that is how
people learn,
right?
If you're a child and you're learning to
master the world,
you actually exist in a state of
existential anxiety unless you're near
someone that will take care of you.
So for example,
if you take the typical child and you'd
go to a mall,
say a three year old and then you have
the three year old Stan and you leave,
it's going to be very long until you're
far enough away so that most of most
children in that situation will
immediately start to cry.
They'll get worried and they'll start to
cry and then they'll break down because,
well,
because that's the existential anxiety
like you think,
well,
a normal child is calm.
It's like wrong.
A normal child close to someone who will
take care of them is calm,
but that is by no means the same thing.
It's not even close to the same thing,
and so if you get backwards in your
psychological thinking,
if you don't notice that because you
think,
well,
the normal human being is calm and well
put together,
it's like no wrong.
The normal human being in a place of
safety is calm and well put together,
but why you would ever think that a
normal place is a place of safety.
You know,
assuming that that's the standard or the
norm,
there's absolutely no reason for that.
You see this with rats too because the
behaviorist,
for example,
made the presumption that you had to
teach rats to be afraid.
But let me tell you how that actually
worked.
It's really interesting and it shows you
how carefully you have to analyze,
say,
psychological experiments to understand
what's going on.
So let's say you take a lab rat,
okay?
Like,
and let's say it's a lab rat.
The rat that skinner used,
bf skinner,
who is the most famous of the behaviors,
and he could get rats to do anything.
He taught pigeons to play ping pong.
He taught pigeons to guide guided
missiles by photographs,
and he did that with behavioral
training.
They were never used for guided missiles
because they got the electronics working
before the program was set into
operation,
but he could get them to peck at photos
to guide something that was flying
accurately.
And he did that with behavioral
training.
So skinner,
I mean,
he,
he was no joke.
He could.
He really knew how to train animals and
it's very useful material to know.
We'll talk about it to some degree if
you want to train children,
for example,
or,
or pets.
So because the learning mechanisms are
very similar,
which is why,
of course we can get along with pets,
right?
We understand them,
like we understand children roughly
speaking.
So anyways,
so let's say you've got your rat and
he's sitting there and he's pretty calm
and he's in his cage.
And so he's already a weird rat because
he's been genetically altered.
He's not a wild Norway rat,
so he's a little tamer than a normal
rat.
Maybe he's a little more fearful,
although perhaps not,
and he's also a solitary rat in his cage
and there's no such thing as a solitary
rat.
It's like a solitary zebra or a solitary
carp or a car.
Cod Cod existed.
Huge schools.
There's no such thing as at cod,
which is why they will never come back
as far as I can tell,
because once you wipe out the school,
it's like you wipe out a beehive and
you're going to have six bees.
What the hell are you going to do with
six bees?
What are they going to do?
They don't exist on their own and,
and,
and hurt animals are like that too.
And caught her like that.
So they organized their mating behavior
in their huge schools.
So without the schools,
like what the hell is the cod going to
do?
Nothing.
And that is what they're doing.
But anyways,
back to the,
back to the rat.
So you've got this rat,
he's in a cage,
he's alone and he's hungry because one
of the things that skinner did was
starve his rats down to 75 percent of
their normal body weight so that they
would respond to a lot more to food.
So,
so that's the model and that you've got
to keep in mind that the nature of the
model,
because the model is like the way the
model is constituted is equivalent to
your implicit assumptions about your
experiment and people don't take that
into consideration.
Okay?
So the rats come.
So then what you do is you take the ride
out of his cage and you put them in the
testing chamber.
And so maybe what you're going to do is
you're going to have set the rat up so
that a light goes on and then he gets a
little electric shock.
Okay?
But,
and now you're going to teach them to be
afraid of the light.
So after you pair the light with the
shock,
six or seven times when the light comes
on,
the rats going to freeze.
So.
And he freezes because he's using
Predator avoidance strategy.
Basically to deal with the threat,
but,
and so you think,
well,
calm rat learns to be afraid,
but no,
because when you put the rat in the
cage,
the new cage,
what does it do?
Well,
it doesn't just,
you know,
find the sofa and have a nap.
It's terrified when he put it in the new
situation,
that's the normal rat.
It's the one that's like this and it
doesn't move because if it moved,
maybe a Predator would pick it out like
a cat because cats can see lateral
movement.
That's why they have slit eyes by the
way,
so they can detect lateral movement and
you know that because if you play with
your cat like this,
it'll chase your hand.
But if you do this,
it won't.
It is because it doesn't chase things
that do.
This doesn't chase kangaroos,
you know,
chase's things that move like this.
So it has eyes for that.
Anyways,
the rats frozen and then it starts to
sniff because Erad is all smell.
Most animals,
most the brains of most animals are
organized around smell.
Human beings are very weird because our
brains are organized around vision.
But that's just not the case for most.
Well,
you know,
dogs,
they're the weirdest things.
A because they can,
they,
they can smell like way better than you.
That can detect odors way better than
you.
Probably most of you smell better than a
dog,
but they,
they can detect odors better than you.
But everything seems to smell good too.
A dog,
which is the strangest damn thing,
you know,
with a nose like that,
you'd think they'd never even want to go
outside.
But anyways.
Oh,
now I probably lost my place.
All right.
Dogs smell.
Where were we going with that?
Rats.
Yes.
And what's that?
Frozen?
Yes.
Okay.
So the rat,
that's the one,
that's the one.
So the rod is in its cage and it's
frozen so that nothing can see it and
eat it.
And so it starts to sniff because it
uses smell to see what's going on.
And so if you take rats that have never
been exposed to a cat and you like blow
cat odor over them,
they do not like that at all.
They didn't not like cat odor.
So it's built right into,
it's an archetype.
The Predator cat is an archetype for the
rat and it doesn't need any,
any pre-training to respond to it and
it's probably also the case with human
beings and things like snakes and
looming objects.
We've got some archetipal predators as
well,
but all right,
so the rat sniffs and then if nothing
happens that thinks okay,
a rad can sniff here without dying.
And so then it starts to relax a little
bit.
Maybe it starts to move around a bit and
it thanks.
Okay.
A sniffing wrap that's moving a little
bit can live here without dying and then
nothing else happens and so it relaxes a
bit more and then it starts to sniff
it's way around and it'll sniff all
around the cage and check out all the
corners and make sure that there isn't
anything there that can eat it because
the rat actually cares about that.
And then when it's completely explored
the cage and decided that it's safe,
then it turns into a normal calm rat.
But that's post exploration.
So you have to say,
well,
a rat that has thoroughly explored it's
territory is a calm rat.
That's a whole different way of looking
about fear.
Then you turn the light on and shock it
and the rat thinks you're wrong.
It's not safe here in that light
indicates so indicates that it's not
safe.
So basically what you've done is
reminded the rack that life is
dangerous.
You have not taught it fear.
It's not the same thing.
The rat knows everything about fear.
It learned that it was safe and it was
wrong.
And that's a really,
really important thing to understand
also about what you're like because you
know per like anxiety that needs no
explanation,
depression that needs no explanation.
What needs explanation is,
how the hell do you ever feel secure and
together ever because that's the
mystery.
And partly the way you do that is by
never going anywhere where you're upset,
you stay in your territory.
And so like this is your territory and
everyone knows how to act here,
right?
So you look around it and everyone's
sitting and doing exactly the same
thing.
So you can ignore them.
You can pretend that they're not
dangerous and most of the time that will
be correct and some of the time it won't
be,
and so you maintain your emotional
stability by staying where you belong
and that's quite different than the
psychoanalytic view.
Psychoanalytic view.
You know that you're.
You're calm and well put together.
If your psyche is properly organized.
It's like,
this is partly why I introduced you guys
to piaget because Piaget adds this other
element,
you know,
he says something like,
yeah,
well your psyche has to be organized
properly so you have to turn.
You have to have turned everything that
is a constituent element of you into a
functional being,
but that being has to be integrated in a
functional game like landscape made of
other people who are doing the same
thing.
And then it's the concordance between
your structure and that landscape that
makes you emotionally regulated.
That's a way different theory.
It's a much more sophisticated theory.
So you could say in some sense the
psychoanalysts had it half right.
You know,
and also you can be individually
pathological in a way that doesn't let
you fit into society.
But you have to understand the
concordance between the social
organization and the Individual
Organization to get the.
To get the picture right.
Well,
so what are the existentialists say?
it's something like in the depths of
your existential terror,
the wisdom to cope with that terror will
be found.
So that's the fundamental idea.
And then there's a.
there's a,
a more profound idea in that which I
would also say is implicit in,
in psychotherapy,
the more behavioral the psychotherapy,
the more implicit it is.
But the idea is that
despite the fact that you are
mismatched,
that you're outmatched by,
let's call it existential complexity.
There's something in you that's far more
complex than you know,
and if you challenge it,
it will respond by growing and
developing.
And that will not protect you against
the existential anxiety.
It's not like a shield or a guard that
you're,
that you're hiding behind.
It's not a defense.
What happens instead is that you
actually learn how to deal with it.
You know,
so you think about it this way.
One of the things that human beings are
archetipal,
he related to his fire and of course
fire is something to be afraid of
because it,
it will burn you and it will burn
everything down,
but by the same token,
when we mastered fire,
which may have been 2 million years ago,
something like that because it looks
like it was about then that we learned
how to cook,
which made a big difference.
So you know how chimps,
I haven't totally the chimps story,
I don't think,
you know,
chimps are sort of shaped like this.
They've got this huge barrel shaped
body.
Well yeah,
they spend like 12 hours a day chewing
leaves.
And why is that?
Because you go out in the forest and eat
leaves and see how much you have to
choose so you don't starve to death.
It's like leaves aren't edible.
They hardly have any nourishment at all.
And so if you're a chimp,
all you do is sit around and chew leaves
and then you need to have an intestinal
track that could wrap two or three times
around this room so that you can digest
the damn things right.
So that's chimp life.
While human beings,
we decided to trade intestinal length
for brain and the way we did that was by
learning how to cook and we mastered
fire.
And so you might say,
well,
is fire dangerous?
And the to that is.
Well,
it depends on how you react to it.
It's exactly that,
right?
You say,
well fire is intrinsically dangerous.
It's like no,
fire is multi valence.
It has all sorts of possibilities and
some of them are extraordinarily
destructive.
But if you match your behavior properly
to the phenomena,
then you can master something like fire.
Well.
So the idea is that there's a potential
inside you.
Whatever inside means there's a
potential that's part of you,
some of it's genetic potential,
and we know that because if we move you
into a new environment,
new genes will turn on inside of you and
manufacturer new parts of you.
So if you stress yourself optimally,
if you push yourself out into the world,
you can incorporate information from
that journey.
You're the exploration.
That's a Piagetian idea,
right?
You,
you go out,
you learn something new.
When you adjust your behavior to it.
And you adjust your concepts to it and
then you can master it.
But what piaget didn't realize was that
it also transforms your biological
structure at a microscopic level merely
as a consequence of being put in the new
situation.
So the idea is that there's more to you
than you know,
and the way you call it out is by
challenging yourself voluntarily in as
many directions as you can manage.
And that's a real thing.
It isn't the construction of defenses.
It's not something artificial like
defense against death,
anxiety.
It's actually how you learn to cope in
the world.
And the existentialists I would say
despite their exceptional pessimism were
in some sense unbelievably optimistic
because what they would say,
it's the opposite of a straw man
argument.
They would say,
well,
how?
How weaker human beings ultimately week
we're,
we're up against an opponent,
so to speak,
social opponents say which would be the
crushing weight of society and a natural
opponent that is nature,
which overwhelms you were up against the
ultimate opponent.
But.
And so in that sense we're
extraordinarily weak.
But it turns out that if we face that
opponent or that series of opponents,
then all sorts of possibilities manifest
themselves inside of us and it isn't
clear what the upper limits are to that.
So it's so interesting that it's a good
example of how if you face what you're
afraid of,
you can find what you need.
He said,
well,
the existentialist make the strongest
case possible for,
for the vulnerability of human beings.
And out of that,
the extract out the strongest case
possible.
Why human beings are strong and
powerful.
It's very interesting paradox.
And again,
I would say that that's central to
psychotherapy.
One of the things you,
one of the things that's been learned
about agoraphobic,
for example,
agoraphobic,
they're usually women.
They're usually in their forties.
They've usually been dependent,
often someone close to them as divorced
or died or they're having heart
palpitations or something like that.
Sometimes as a consequence of menopause
and they've,
they've accustomed themselves to seeking
authority when challenged.
But the problem with having heart
palpitations is like,
who's going to help you with that?
Well,
maybe you go to the emergency room and
that is what agoraphobic do.
Most agoraphobic,
so have been to the emergency room like
a dozen times because they have heart
palpitations and then they feel them.
Then they get afraid and panic.
Then their heart rate goes way up and
then they think,
oh my God,
I'm going to die and while I do it while
I die,
I'm going to make an absolute fool of
myself and everyone's going to laugh at
me.
So that's social rejection and
biological mortality.
Staring them right in the face.
Well,
so then you take an agoraphobic and you
find out her background because as I
said,
it's usually women and then you start to
expose that person to the things that
she's afraid of.
Elevators,
maybe subways,
taxis actually agoraphobic.
Really what happens is they're not
really so much afraid of of places or
things.
What they're afraid of is being trapped
in a place or a situation where they
can't get away and then if they had a
heart attack,
they wouldn't be able to get to an
emergency ward.
So that's really at the basis of the
fear and so on.
The emergency roared reward thing only
helps to a limited degree because if
you're having a heart attack and it's a
really good one,
your dad and so the.
So that's a place where recourse to
authority is only going to take you so
far.
Right?
So it's a,
it's a,
it's not a good solution to the problem.
Well,
so what do you do?
you expose the person maybe to an
elevator and you know,
maybe the elevator is there and you tell
them,
well can you get on an elevator?
And they say no.
Say Well can you look at an elevator
while?
I don't think so.
Well,
how about some pictures of an elevator?
So you show them some pictures of an
elevator on Google and maybe one with
closed doors and one with open doors and
you have them look at the damn thing
because they won't want to look.
They'll want to look away,
but you can't look away.
You have to investigate it.
And then what your brain learns is that
you're afraid of that thing,
but you can scan it with your eyes and
nothing happens.
It's like the rat in the cage sniffing
and realizing,
well,
he can sniff it and he doesn't die.
It's like you can look at the picture of
an elevator and you don't die.
Well,
you do that until you're bored and not.
That's then you've learned that you can
look at that elevator without dying.
It's built right into you.
Well then maybe I can take you out and
we'll look at a real elevator.
And so you.
I say,
well,
let's walk as close to that elevator is
you can manage.
I want you right on the edge between
order and chaos.
Let's say.
I want you to find that edge.
Can you.
Can you stand here?
Yes.
How about here?
How about that's good enough.
Okay.
You're standing here,
order chaos.
That's where you're at.
So what happens?
You stand there and you notice you don't
die and you do that long enough so
you're bored with it.
And then you think,
well,
can you step three feet closer?
Yes,
you can.
Well,
and maybe after three weeks you say,
well,
we're by the door,
so here's the deal.
I'm going to open that door and I'm
going to hold it open and I'm not going
to play a trick on you,
and so what you're going to do is just
poke your head in and take a around,
and so imagine doing that.
Okay,
so you imagine it.
now actually do it.
Then I know I don't let go of the door.
That's what evil psychotherapists do
anyways.
Then you get the person inside and what
you see is they're looking at their
shoes.
They're in there,
but they're not really in there.
He say,
no,
no.
You gotta.
Look,
you gotta.
Look in the corners.
You've got to look at the numbers.
You've got to see that you're in this
thing that you're afraid of,
and so you have them look around and
look around and look around.
They're like the rat coming,
relaxing and starting to move.
Then you say,
well,
that's good enough.
You can get out of the elevator slowly.
Don't rush out.
Just go out Carmley.
Good enough.
Go home,
sleep for a week and then come back and
we'll do it again.
And then if you do that for it depends
on how fast the person is capable of
advancing,
but you can move people through phobias
pretty fast if they trust you and they
have to trust you and you have to be
careful.
You say you say to them,
look,
we will stop doing this whenever you
want.
As soon as you say so.
So this is,
this is completely up to you.
I'm not pushing you.
I've got no demands on you.
You want to be able to go outside again,
we're gonna.
Walk through that,
but you're not performing for me.
This isn't a test,
this isn't a contest,
it's none of that.
And when you're done,
we're done.
And you know,
you can also have help people like step
through that.
So I was treating someone who had a
needle phobia recently and this person
really felt trapped by authority figures
that were medical and this person had
their reasons for it.
And so the first thing I did because we
were working with this needle was say
you're going to practice getting the
hell out of here.
So I'll come at you.
I'll come at you with this needle,
you know,
I don't have a needle,
but we'll pretend I do.
Okay.
So I'm going to move it towards you and
you're going to tell me to stop and
you're going to leave the room because
you want to see that you can't,
you know,
and the person will think,
well,
I know I can.
It's like,
no,
you don't.
No,
you don't know.
And so we're going to practice it just
like a kid pretending.
And so I moved forward with the
nonexistent needle and they say stop.
And I stopped and they say I'm leaving.
And they leave and they come back and
they're smiling because they didn't know
they could do that.
You know,
in part of them is still thinking,
well I'm a four year old kid and there's
no way I can get out of here.
No one's gonna.
Listen to me.
It's built right into them.
That's like Freud and regression or
fixation.
At an earlier developmental stages,
if you watch that with you,
watch for that in people.
Sometimes you can see how old they are,
you know,
if you.
If you tap into something that they were
afraid of very young,
their whole facial expression will turn
into that person their body language and
everything.
It's very interesting to watch very
carefully to see it,
but you can definitely see it.
So okay.
So with the agoraphobic you think,
well you treat the Agora phobic,
you know,
and then she can go take taxis and she'd
go on the subway and then she goes and
has a big fight with her husband because
she showed it had 1:20 years ago.
But she was dependent and authority
seeking so she never would risk it
because if she upset the relationship
with authority that it would expose her
to the world.
And so she was always in a subordinate
and inferior position and a bit of a
slave.
And one of the things that often happens
when you treat someone with Agora
Phobias,
they get a lot more assertive and you
think,
well,
one of the things the psychoanalysts
objected to when the behaviors started
to use exposure therapy as a treatment
was the idea that there would be
substitution because the psychoanalyst
would say,
you're not really afraid of an elevator.
So if I just treat your elevator fear
because that's really not what you're
afraid of,
the fear is just going to pop up
somewhere else.
That'd be symbolic substitution.
But that isn't what happened.
What happened was is that if they learn
to get on the elevator,
they are much more likely to take a
taxi.
You think,
well,
why is that?
It's because they weren't learning.
The things were less frightening.
That was the original idea.
The original idea was counter
conditioning that basically the person
had been conditioned to be afraid of
whatever it was and then what you did
was you put them in an encounter with
that and you let them breathe and relax
and then the relaxation they learned
would counteract the panic.
And that's why exposure therapy work.
But it turned out you didn't need to do
any of that.
It wasn't counter conditioning at all.
And so then you think,
well,
it's fear reduction or habituation.
That was the next theory.
Habituation is just take a snail.
He comes out of his shell,
you poke them,
he goes into his shell and he comes out
to get poke sell.
You tease a snail if you,
if you,
you know,
if you ever need to know that.
So he comes out and you tap them and you
do that 10 or 15 times the snail gets
bored and you tap him.
He just sits there.
Now he doesn't get bored because snails
are probably always,
always board.
But what's happened is that you've,
in some sense,
you've exhausted the nervous system
representation.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Or you can think about it as a very
simple form of learning.
That's habituation.
It's learn,
you learn to ignore.
And the idea then for a while was that
you were teaching people to habituate to
these things they were afraid of,
but that also turned out not to be true.
What you're actually doing is teaching
the person to be brave and that
generalizes,
so what happens is they think they're
all pathetic and and,
and,
and fear ridden and tiny and vulnerable
and useless and and so they're acting
like that and then you say,
well look,
this is a horrible thing you've got
here.
Why don't we see if you can manage it?
And so they go through it and they
think,
wow,
I could do that.
Hi,
I'm not as useless as I thought,
and then maybe they try 20 things like
that and they think,
wow,
I'm a lot tougher than I knew I was.
Maybe they stand up a little bit
straighter because they're a little more
dominant in their serotonin system.
Start to work again,
and then they're ready to take on the
world more.
And so maybe that's why they go home and
have a fight with their stupid husband
and that doesn't necessarily make him
very happy either.
And that would be a,
an example of psychotherapy,
pubic resistance from a family member.
Do you really want your person to be
better?
Right.
If they are a little more assertive and
little less fearful,
you might not be able to tyrannize over
them so easily and so it's not
necessarily the case at all that you
would be happy about that,
so you've got to watch that sort of
thing too,
and maybe the person wouldn't even be
that happy about it because they're
getting all sorts of secondary benefits
from being neurotic and martyred because
that's how vicious weapon to be weak and
useless.
If you can wield that as a weapon,
it's extraordinarily effective.
So you gotta watch for that sort of
thing to be working against your
psychotherapeutic aims as well.
Like Psychoanalysis,
existentialism seeks to utilize these
very conflicts as avenues to the more
profound self understanding of mat.
In many ways,
existential invisible existentialism is
the unique and specific portrayal of the
psychological predicament of
Contemporary Matt.
Okay,
so that relates back to the idea that
modern people have been stripped of
their archaic belief systems that are
exposed more completely to to the
possibility of a meaningless and painful
existence with no superordinate,
meaning.
Existentialism is not a school of
thought nor reduceable to one set of
tenants.
The three writers who appear invariably
on every list of existentialists,
existentialist,
Heidegger,
and Sartre are not in agreement on
essentials,
such a legend precursors as Pascal and
kierkegaard differed from all three men
by being dedicated Christians and Pascal
was a catholic of sorts while
Kierkegaard was a Protestant Protestant.
If there's often done Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky or included in the fold,
then we must make room for an
impassioned Antichristian,
Nicha and an even more fanatical Greek
Orthodox Russian imperialist.
That's a little hard on Dostoevsky I
would say,
but by the time we consider adding real
key CAFCA Ortega and come to it became
plain that one essential features shared
by all these men is their preferred
individualism.
Well,
so that's another element of
existentialism.
The locale of action is in the
individual and the idea is that well,
you're faded in some sense to suffer and
to be vulnerable as an individual.
And so the right unit of analysis for
people is as individuals,
and again,
I would say that's a primary tenant of
psychotherapy.
There are family psychotherapy schools.
For example,
but individual psychotherapy is
predicated on the idea that the
individual is the right level of
analysis,
the correct level of analysis,
intense,
committed.
I can give you an interesting example of
this.
One of the things that you guys are
going to do is you're going to do the
personality analysis,
which is part of this self authoring
suite that my colleagues and I have have
developed.
If you take maps of meaning,
you would also do the future authoring
exercise and we've done that for people,
mostly university students mostly in
Europe.
So I want to tell you an interesting
story and this has been replicated a
couple of times.
So in the business school at at the
Rotterdam School of Management,
we've tested.
We've put about 4,000 students through
this future authoring program.
That helps you make a plan for three to
five years into the future.
A plan and a counter plan.
The plan is what you want to have happen
and the counter plan is what you really
do not want to have happen,
and then you make a plan to avoid the
ladder and to move towards the former.
And we compared their performance three
years per students performance to the
performance of students three years
before that.
So it wasn't a perfect design,
although we also did a controlled study
that had the same results.
So when,
when we started,
before we started having people do this
plan here was the ranking of
performance.
So we looked at ethnicity,
ethnicity,
and gender.
So the top performing people were Dutch
national women and they were a minority
among the business students and probably
a fairly selected minority.
So maybe that's what accounted for their
higher performance.
Although women tend to be outperforming
men in academic institutions pretty much
all the way from elementary school
through university now.
Just an absolute catastrophe.
But we won't talk about that now.
So.
And then the next highest performing
group were Dutch nationals and then the
next highest performing group were
nonwestern ethnic minority women and the
lowest performing group or West
nonwestern,
west non ethnic minority men.
And there were quite a few people in all
those categories.
So it wasn't just even a couple dozen.
It was a couple of hundred solid study.
And within two years after doing the
future authoring program,
the nonwestern ethnic minority men were
outperforming the Dutch women.
They're their academic performance,
went up 70 percent and their dropout
rate plummeted and it really looks good
for decreasing dropout rate.
And the reason I'm telling you about
that is because people make the
automatic assumption that ethnic
disparities and ethnic performance are
necessarily a consequence of
sociological inequality,
let's say,
or sociological or political or economic
disparity.
Let's say this was a pure psychological
intervention.
It wiped out the difference completely
and the Dutch women had actually
improved slightly over that two year
period as a consequence of doing the
program as well.
So the man not only caught up to the
women the way they were performing,
but the way they were performing even
better in the in the aftermath of having
a plant.
So our provisional theory,
we've replicated that at a couple of
places.
It works better for men.
Now that's partly because women are
already doing well,
but we have a hypothesis that men are
ordinary enough so that unless they have
their own plan and they just won't
perform.
I think it's associated with
disagreeableness now we don't know that
for sure because we haven't been able to
disentangle that,
but it's been a very striking finding.
So anyway,
so you can say,
well,
what's the right level of analysis when
you're trying to to improve human
adaptation?
Terrible word,
but,
but it'll do for now because I can't
think of another one.
So
the refusal to belong to any school of
thought,
the repudiation of the adequacy of any
body of beliefs,
whatever and especially of systems and a
market dissatisfaction with traditional
philosophy as academic and remote from
life.
That's the heart of existentialism and I
think that if you're a good
psychotherapist,
you take an existential approach to your
clients and that's why listening is so
important as well because it's really
useful to have a body of theories about
what might be up with a person and how
you might approach the problem and to
have a whole array of psychotherapeutic
tools.
So those would be the.
The theories that we've been discussing
opens up your,
your.
It makes you more skilled,
it gives you more,
more to offer,
but you've got to be careful not to
hammer the person into one of those
schools.
Now,
sometimes that's useful because if
someone comes to you and they're just
chaotic,
they've got no structure at all.
If you approach them as if their
problems were Friday and at least it's
systematic and they can come out with a
systematic understanding of their
problem and it might match to some
degree,
like you know,
if you're having all sorts of anxiety
and depression problems,
we could probably look into your family
history and identify reasons why that
might be at least partly the case and so
at at least a reasonable.
Maybe there's multiple reasons,
but at least nailing one of them would
be useful.
More useful than nailing none of them.
So.
But what's better is to treat the person
as someone you don't know.
You have no idea what's up with this
person,
but you have a bunch of potential tools
to use and then you talk to them and you
treat them as if they're unique and
you've figured out what is up with them.
Specifically,
and they tell you what's up with him,
you know,
they've got all sorts of cockeyed
theories about who they are and what
they're doing and it's scattered and
paradoxical and it doesn't make much
sense and it's like a bad undergraduate
essay.
Roughly speaking.
It's full.
Well really it's full of internal
contradictions and it's incoherent,
but if you listen long enough,
that stops being the case.
The person starts to pull themselves
together with their representation and
they start to act that out properly and
that's great,
so that that's.
That's you could consider that applied
existentialism.
Now
the other thing,
the existentialists,
that kind of romantic,
I would say even the Romantics are are
thinkers who who deny the overarching
supremacy of rationality and the
intellect.
They would say that to think about life
as a problem that is to be solved
rationally is insufficient because
you're not a rational being or you're
only partly a rational being.
You're also an emotional being and
you're a motivated being and you're an
embodied being and that's a lot
different than being purely rational and
I would say there's actually not even
debate about that anymore because it,
it,
it's pretty damn clear that rationality
cannot really operate unless it's
embodied.
So it has a,
it has a set of operations that it can
undertake that it's motivated so that
there's certain things it's doing and
other things that aren't,
that it isn't,
that it's emotional because emotions are
low resolution,
quick solutions to problems that can't
be computed.
So for example,
we get in an argument and we just can't
go anywhere and at some point you say,
well to hell with you,
I'm going home.
You're angry when.
Well,
no,
but you don't have to have the stupid
argument anymore.
So the anger is actually,
it's a way of popping you out of a
rational framework that there's no
escaping from.
You just say,
well,
this is stupid and you leave.
It's like there's nothing rational about
that except that you don't want to stand
there and argue till you starve to
death.
So.
So we need the emotions to give you
guides in situations that you can't
really compute your way through,
so and only inside of that does
rationality operate with all of those
underlying predicates and the
rationality has to be informed by the
body and by the motivations and by the
emotions for it to even operate.
So the existentialists are correct about
that too.
To deny rationality as the fundamental
principle of orientation.
That doesn't mean that irrationality is
the right approach.
It means that rationality has to be
augmented by other elements of being.
I'll almost have subjective big,
and that's akin to the psychoanalytic
viewpoint too,
that you have to integrate your drives
and emotions,
especially anger and sexuality into your
personality.
And also akin to Piaget's idea that this
subpersonalities,
the reflexes and so forth have to be,
you know,
jen have to be organized into a playable
game so that everything is working in
harmony.
So it's a similar idea.
Now the existentialists regard the
division between object and subject as
part of what specifically torturing
people who are outside of say,
traditional systems of belief.
Because,
and this is a tricky one,
you know,
scientists might claim that while the
world has material and matter is spent
essentially dead and without spirit or
or,
or psyche,
but,
and it's easy as a consequence of
adopting that viewpoint to think the
same thing about you,
that you're ultimately a shortlived
material entity in a meaningless
material world.
But the weird thing about that,
and this is where thinking about is that
if you're a scientist,
you throw away this objective as soon as
you start operating the science because
the idea is,
well,
you'll watch something according to a
procedure and you'll watch it and you'll
watch it and you'll watch it and we're
only going to allow what all have you
experienced the same way to be real
while you throw out the subjective right
at the beginning and then you.
So you can't say,
well,
there's no subject left in what results.
It's the reason there's nothing left in
what results is because you throw it out
to begin with.
Now the question is,
what should you do with it?
When the existentialists say,
well,
you're alive.
You can't just dispense with it.
The fact that you're alive is the
critical issue and so you can use
science as a tool which is proper,
but if you use it as a way of describing
being well,
then you fall into this subject object
dichotomy and underneath that is
nihilism or the proclivity for
totalitarianism,
so they don't like that idea.
They don't like the idea of
compartmentalization for people either,
but we won't go into that to any great
degree.
Okay.
Now I'm going to read you some things
from some of the people that I described
and we'll take them apart a little bit.
Things I've been collecting for a long
period of time.
So this is Nietzsche,
Dostoevsky and Kierkegaard and I called
them prophets of the dawning age care.
Kguard.
The Danish philosopher and writer was
really the first person who wrote about
phenomena like anxiety,
dread and,
and,
and more particularly.
So he was the first person to sort of
conceptualized it as a,
as even as something akin to a
scientific phenomena.
Something that had existence.
And he wrote very much about that.
Nature,
of course was the great prophet of the
death of God.
And and a prognosticator of what the
psychological consequences of the demise
of this classic meaning structure that
was unbelievably ancient.
What what the collapse of that actually
meant to meet you meet you can think
about Christianity and then maybe you
could think about the Judaism that was
embedded in as it even an older system,
but that judy is an emerged out of the
Middle East,
partly out of Egypt,
which was it immeshed and even an older
belief system and that was in meshed in
something absolutely prehistoric that
and so it was a continuum in some sense
of adaptive structures that reigned
supreme essentially right until while
right until the scientific revolution,
and so we're outside of that now we're
in a different paradigm and there are
consequences to that and that was the
sort of thing that Nisha was
concentrating on it.
He actually in some ways made it worse
because Nisha was an incredible critic
of Christianity.
I mean,
he wrote a book called the antichrist
and all he did in that book brilliantly
was take dogmatic Christianity to task.
Now,
one of the things he did say,
which was very interesting was that
Christianity died at its own hand,
so his notion was that because
Christianity say Judaeo,
Christianity had elevated truth to the
highest virtue,
that that search for truth then ended up
undermining the axioms of Christianity
itself.
So it developed a tool,
an unbelievably powerful analytic tool,
and then used it to.
Well,
it's like we were sitting on a branch
and started off with the saw that we had
invented and then everyone fell and
Dostoevsky.
Well,
Dostoevsky was a orthodox Christian and,
and,
but,
and also an extraordinarily brilliant
man and he was absolutely terrified at,
uh,
at what the consequences of the
dissolution of that belief system was
going to mean for Russia in particular.
And Dostoevsky explored nihilism,
great unit to great degree in notes from
underground and in crime and punishment
because the murderer and crime and
punishment is essentially nihilistic.
He's a nihilistic narcissist,
roughly speaking,
and that's what compels them to commit
murder.
But Dostoevsky also wrote a book called
the Devil's,
which is an amazing book where he
predicted that the death of the sudden
death of Christianity in the Soviet in
Russia was going to produce the
catastrophic totalitarian horrors of the
Soviet Union,
and he predicted that in like 18,
80,
1890,
which was 30 years before the
revolution,
absolutely remarkable
nature,
a genius nature was a full professor
when that was impossible,
I think when he was 24 and that just
never happened.
And so his.
His extraordinary genius was recognized
very early and but he was also
extraordinarily ill,
sick physically.
His Dad died at about 40 something they
called a softening of the brain,
which was actually a fairly common
diagnostic category back then.
No one really knows what it was.
Some people have suggested that he had
syphilis from one sexual encounter or
that it was hereditary,
but nobody really knows.
But anyways,
his father died.
Young and nature died very young as
well.
He went,
he was very.
He was mentally incapacitated for the
last few years of his life and died and
died after that.
And so he could only serve as a
professor for a while because he
couldn't see very well and he was always
sick and he ended up living in this
little village,
I believe in Switzerland where he wrote
his books and he could only write a
paragraph or two at a time without
before he became very ill.
And so his writing is extraordinary.
Condensed in dance and brilliant,
brilliant.
And he's,
I think he gave away,
I think,
beyond good and evil,
which is his masterpiece,
although we had many,
I think it only sold 500 copies in his
lifetime.
So he,
he also believed that he was only
writing for himself.
He didn't really know if anybody was
ever going to pay any attention to what
he said,
but they certainly did.
So I would say he was.
He ended up being certainly one of the
10 most influential people of the late
19th and early 20th century.
This is an example of his writing of
what is great.
One must either be silent or speak with
greatness,
with greatness.
That means cynically and with innocence.
What I relate is the history of the next
two centuries.
I described what is coming,
what can no longer come differently,
the advent of nihilism,
our whole European culture
is moving from some time now,
moving for some time now with a tortured
tension that is growing from decade to
decade as towards a catastrophe
restlessly violently headlong like a
river that wants to reach the end that
no longer reflects,
that's afraid to reflect.
He that speaks here has conversely
nothing so far but to reflect as a
philosopher and solitary by instinct who
has found his advantage in standing,
aside outside.
Why has the advent of nihilism become
necessary?
Sorry about that because the values we
have had hitherto thus draw their final
consequence because nihilism represents
the ultimate logical conclusion of our
great values and ideals.
Because we must experience nihilism
before we can find out what value those
values really had.
We require at some time,
new values.
Nihilism stands at the door.
Whence comes this uncanny of all guests.
Point of departure.
This is a good example of how Nisha.
Nisha said he philosophized with a
hammer and and it's,
it's,
it means that he spent hours,
days,
weeks,
months concentrating on how to make a
single sentence as packed with
significance as he could possibly
manage.
And so nature said it's the best
arrogant statement I've ever read.
He said,
I can say in a sentence
what it takes other people,
a whole book to say,
and then he said what?
What they can't say in a whole book.
That's pretty good day.
It's like the first one's a real blow to
the solar plexus and the second one is
like,
I can top that with no problem.
Point of departure.
It is an error to consider social
distress or physiological degeneration
or the corruption of all things as the
cause of nihilism.
That's a critique of the later Freudian
ideas right there and then because what
niches says would look if things are
going wrong for you or if they're going
wrong.
In general,
it's really straightforward to say that,
well,
there's something wrong with society
that would be social distress or there's
some physiological degeneration.
There's some thing wrong with you
physically or everything is just
corrupted.
Being itself is corrupt,
which is a classic explanation,
right?
You hear that all the time.
You think,
well,
people are suffering for one reason or
another.
Well,
why?
there's something wrong biologically,
or society is corrupted and everything
is unfair.
Nietzsche says,
no,
you're not going to get away with that.
First.
He says,
ours is the most honest and
compassionate age comparing modern
civilization.
Let's say to everything that that has
come before it,
so speaking of corruption is not
something you can do lightly,
and then he says,
and this is remarkable distress,
whether psychic,
physical,
or intellectual,
need not at all produced nihilism.
That is the radical rejection of value,
meaning and desirability.
Such distress always permits a variety
of interpretations.
Well,
that's a rough one.
It's like,
well,
you had a rough childhood.
Well,
someone else who had your childhood
might not have drawn those conclusions.
So here's an example.
You know that most people who abuse
children were abused by chilled with as
children,
right?
But most people who were abused as
children do not grow up to abuse
children,
and you can figure that out,
arithmetically,
because if it was,
if it was the case that everyone abused
grew up to abuse in about four
generations,
everyone would be being beat to death in
childhood as a matter of course,
because it would spread exponentially.
That isn't what happens.
It dampens.
And why is that?
Well,
if you're bullied as a child,
we could say,
well,
you could draw to conclusions.
Causal Conclusions being bullied caused
me to be a bully.
Fair enough,
man.
That's an understandable story.
How about being bullied caused me not
ever to be a bully?
Well,
why is that any less reasonable
conclusion?
It's frequently one that people draw,
and since the two opposite conclusions
can be drawn from the same set of
experiences,
you cannot say that the experience has
caused the conclusions.
And that's Nietzsche's critique of say,
sociological or psychological
determinism with regards to the optimism
or pessimism.
Pessimism of your worldview.
Such distress always permits a variety
of interpretations,
right?
Rather it isn't one particular
interpretation.
The Christian moral one,
that nihilism is rooted the end of
Christianity at the hands of its own
morality that was the development of the
sense of truth which cannot be replaced,
which turns against the Christian God.
The sense of truthfulness highly
developed I Christianity is nauseated by
the falseness and mendacious ness of all
Christian interpretations of the world
and of history.
A remarkable claim,
and then this one's even worse.
It's absolutely brilliant.
I think rebound from God is truth to the
fanatical faith.
All his false that's nihilism and active
Buddhism and Nietzsche.
Nietzsche explains that,
and this is,
you know,
I talked to you guys a little bit about
the idea of the game and the metagame,
the metagame being the set of all games
niche.
It draws on a conception like that for
this criticism because he says,
when you lose faith in something,
and that happens to people very
frequently,
when you lose faith in something because
you're human and because you can
abstract,
it's not only that you lose faith in
that thing,
that person,
that system,
the fact that you've lost faith in that
indicates to you that it's possible to
lose faith in anything in every system
and every person once burnt,
forever shy,
and that's nihilism.
The fact that one thing can collapse on
you can make you completely unwilling to
manifest any faith in anything
whatsoever,
and that's the emergence of nihilism.
The end of the moral interpretation of
the world which no longer has any
sanction after it has tried to escape
into beyond lie leads to nihilism.
Another critique of Christianity
embedded in that sentence,
he said,
well,
Christiana needed,
needed to be destroyed even by itself
because it puts so much emphasis on the
afterworld on heaven that it forgot
completely about life now and here and
because of that needed to be destroyed
because life here is sufficiently rife
with suffering.
So it needs to be addressed and people,
it's,
it's wrong,
it's incorrect to inform people that
they should wait for some hereafter and
justify their suffering in that manner,
and so he would say in some sense that
even the idea of compassion,
which is central to Christianity,
is also one of the reasons why
Christianity collapsed under its own
weight,
the untenable realty of one
interpretation of the world upon which a
tremendous amount of energy has been
lavished,
awakens the suspicion that all
interpretations of the world or false.
Well,
so what you might say,
well,
so what if you don't believe in
anything?
Well,
I would take a neuro psychological
approach to that.
Most of the positive emotions,
positive emotions,
dopaminergic.
It's a consequence of the manifestation
of the exploratory system that has its
roots in the Hypothalamus,
a very ancient part of the brain.
It's the same part of the brain that
cocaine and heroin and all the drugs
that people like to abuse,
the drugs that are exciting,
not the drugs that are calming.
It activates that system.
It's the system that's activated when
something exciting happens to you or
when something novel happens to you,
but more importantly,
it's the system that's activated when
you're pursuing a goal and you see that
you're moving towards the goal,
so what does that mean?
No goal,
no positive emotion,
so we say,
well,
if you have nothing to believe in,
if you have no value structure,
laugh because value structure says this
is better than this.
No value structure,
no positive emotion while on.
So what's the problem with that?
It's easy to get rid of your positive
emotion.
That's not a problem because it's rather
fragile and tenuous.
Try getting rid of your negative
emotion.
Good luck.
That is not going to happen.
So what happens is that if your value
system collapses,
then all you're left with is negative
emotion and that is not a good thing.
Well,
so neat.
You would say,
well,
why do people flee into the arms of
totalitarians from the specter of
nihilism?
It's because totalitarian certainty,
even though it involves slavery and the
sacrifice of the of reason and
intellect,
totalitarian certainty might be
preferable to nihilistic chaos.
Well,
it's a big problem,
it's a,
and he said,
well,
I'm telling the story of the next 200
years.
It's like,
well,
ever since then,
for the entire 20th century,
we bounced between nihilism and
totalitarianism with deaths on both
sides,
constant and we're still doing exactly
the same thing.
Dostoevsky Dostoevsky was a big
influence on nature and it's very
interesting to read them in parallel
because nature Dostoevsky is of course a
dramatist and Nietzsche as a
philosopher,
and it's almost as if Dostoevsky wrote,
the drama and nature provided.
The philosophical commentary are very,
very powerful to read together.
This is from notes from underground.
It was a very short book about this
character who was a bureaucrat,
nasty sort of bureaucrat.
He knows he's a nasty sort of
bureaucrat.
All he does is he spends his whole life
trying to make life more miserable for
people because he's so resentful and and
crushed and weak,
and so he.
He just not did nothing but abuse is
bureaucratic position and used his
trivial bit of power to Lord it over
people.
He gets a little bit of an inheritance
and quits and this is his confession
notes from underground.
He's the underground.
Matt.
It's brilliant book.
It's viciously funny and it's so
psychologically alive if you're.
If you're interested in psychology.
It's a spectacular book and it's only
about 100 pages long.
Anyways,
he's arrogant and nihilistic and
resentful and what he does is he tries
to justify his life to himself and does
a very poor job of it even though he's
trying to be honest.
There's a lot of honesty in it.
At one point,
he meets a woman who's been forced out
onto the streets because there weren't
very many options for women in the
Victorian period who,
who had fallen afoul of economic
necessity and he basically in a fit of
false messianism offers to save her,
which he can't because he's completely
useless.
He can't save himself even,
but he offers to save her and she more
or less accepts.
And then when she shows up,
having sacrificed a tremendous amount to
do so,
he basically tells her that he was
toying with her and joking and,
and,
and makes her situation far worse than
it was to begin with.
It's a brilliant book because you see,
he repents.
He says what he's like,
he's this horrible person.
He knows that we can resentful.
And then he confesses and then he says,
well,
now I've confessed I'm a better person.
Then he tries to do something good,
but he hasn't changed a bloody bit,
not a bit.
The confession was just to make himself
feel better.
And so he offers to help someone and
pulls them right into the right under
the water where they drown.
It's an amazing book,
and this is from notes from underground.
In short,
one may say anything about the history
of the world,
anything that might enter the most
disordered imagination.
The only thing one can't say is that
it's rational.
The very word sticks in one's throat.
This is a good example of the
existential criticism of the idea of
rationality.
Dostoevsky says,
well,
lots of things operate according to
rational principles,
but let's think about history for a
minute,
especially from the perspective of a
thinking and feeling bid.
Being history is,
uh,
is a slaughterhouse.
It's a catastrophe.
And how would you ever consider that
something rational Dostoevsky's pointed
is rationality fails in its analysis of
something as complex and terrible,
his history,
the only thing one can't say is that
it's rational.
The very word sticks in one's throat in
short,
one may,
sorry,
and indeed this is the odd thing that is
continually happening.
There are continually turning up in
life,
moral and rational persons,
sages,
lovers of humanity who make it their
object to live all their lives as
morally and rationally as possible.
So to be,
to me,
so to speak,
a light to their neighbors simply in
order to show them that it is possible
to live morally and rationally in this
world.
And you have to.
We all know that those very people,
sooner or later have been false to
themselves playing some queer trick
often,
uh,
most unseemly one net.
Now I asked you what can be expected of
man since he is a being endowed with
such strange qualities.
This is a criticism of utopianism.
That's what he's trying to do,
right?
Because the Utopian ideas were starting
to emerge in Russia at about this point
in the 18 eighties.
The idea that you could reorganize
society so that material privation would
disappear and that as a consequence,
the paradise would be ushered in.
Well,
Dostoevsky was no fool.
He knew perfectly well a that that was
never going to happen,
but even more importantly that if you
gave people exactly what they wanted,
even what they needed,
there's no reason whatsoever to presume
that that would make them any more sane
than than they already are now.
And then he takes that further because
he says,
well,
you can give people cake and and
material goods until they're satiated
and they'll still be ungrateful and
insane,
and you might think,
well,
that's pessimistic,
but then he says,
well,
wait a minute.
What makes you think that that insanity
isn't exactly what's valuable about
people?
What makes you think you would ever want
to take that away?
And that's the case that he makes shower
upon him,
every earthly blessing,
drowning in a sea of happiness so that
nothing but bubbles of bliss can be seen
on the surface,
give them economic prosperity,
such that he should have nothing else to
do,
but sleep,
eat cakes and busy himself with the
continuation of his species.
And even then out of sheer in gratitude,
man would play you some nasty trick.
He would even.
Risk is cakes and we're deliberately
desire the most faithful rubbish,
the most uneconomical absurdity simply
to introduce into all this positive,
good sense,
his faithful,
fantastic element.
It is just as fantastic dreams is
vulgar.
Folly that he will desire to retain
simply in order to prove to himself as
though that were so necessary that men
are still men and not the keys of a
piano,
which the laws of nature threatened to
control so completely that soon one will
be able to desire nothing but by the
calendar.
And that is not all.
If even if men really were nothing but a
piano key,
even if this was proved to him by
natural science and mathematics,
even then he would not become reasonable
but would purposely do something
perverse out of simply in gratitude
simply to gain his point,
and if he does not find means he will
contrive destruction and chaos will
contrive suffering of all sorts just to
gain his point.
He will launch a curse upon the world
and this as men is the only animal that
can curse.
It's his privilege.
The primary distinction between him and
other animals,
maybe various curse alone he will attain
is object that is to convince himself
that he's a man and not a piano key,
and if you say that all of this too can
be calculated and tabulated chaos and
darkness and curses so that the mere
possibility of calculating it all
beforehand would stop.
It all and reason would reassert itself
than man would purposely go bad.
In order to be rid of reason and gain
his point.
I believe in it.
I answer for it.
For the whole work of man really seems
to consist in nothing but proving to
himself every minute that he's a man and
not a piano key.
It might be at the cost of his skin,
it might be by cannibalism and this
being so can can one help being tempted
to rejoice that it has not yet come off
and that desire is still depends on
something we don't know are you will
scream at me.
That is if you condescend to do so,
that no one is touching my freewill,
that all they're concerned with is that
my will should have of itself of its own
free will coincide with my own normal
interests,
with the laws of nature and arithmetic.
Good Heavens.
Gentlemen,
what sort of free will is left when we
come to tabulation and arithmetic when
it will all be a matter of twice two,
makes four,
twice.
Two makes four without my will,
as if freewill meant that.
It's brilliant.
I think it's one of the most remarkable
criticisms of utopianism I've ever read.
It's like,
and it's so.
It's so intelligent.
It's like what makes you think that if
you had everything you asked for that
that would satisfy you?
What?
What if being dissatisfied is part of
what satisfies you?
What if the fact that you have to have
limits and need them and that there's an
element of insanity in the world and if
there's an element of insecurity and
vulnerability,
what if that's what you need?
What if it's what you want?
It's what if that's what gives your
life,
meaning you're going to be like a lion
after it's eaten a zebra and do nothing
but sleep that hardly constitutes the
appropriate human paradise.
What makes people think that merely
providing economic security would be
sufficient?
Who wants that?
It's what you.
It's what you offer a cow in its pen so
that it remains calm and fat.
It's not something for human beings and
that's niches.
Fundamental point,
and he formulated that what 40 years
before the dam Soviet revolution,
when that sort of utopianism was put
into practice without absolutely
catastrophic consequences.
Kierkegaard,
it is now about four years ago that I
got the notion
of wanting to try my luck as an author.
I remember it quite clearly.
It was on a Sunday.
Yeah,
that's it.
A Sunday afternoon,
I was seated at usual out of doors at
the cafe in the Fredericksburg.
I had been a student for half a score of
years,
although never lazy.
All my activity nevertheless was like a
glittering inactivity,
a kind of occupation for which I still
have a great partiality and for which
perhaps are even have a little genius.
I read much spending the remainder of
the day idling and thinking
or thinking an idling,
but that was all it came to,
so I sat there and smoke my cigar until
I lapsed into thought among other
thoughts.
I remember these you are going on.
I said to myself to become an old man
without being anything and without
really undertaking to do anything.
On the other hand,
wherever you look about you in
literature and in life,
you see the celebrated names and
figures.
The precious had much heralded man who
are coming into prominence center much
talked about the many benefactors of the
age who know how to benefit mankind by
making life easier and easier.
Some by railways,
somebody omnibuses and steamboats,
others by the telegraph,
others by easily apprehended compendiums
and short recitals of everything worth
knowing,
and finally the true benefactors of the
age you make spiritual existence in
virtue of thought easier and easier,
yet more and more significant.
And what are you doing here?
My soliloquy boy was interrupted because
my cigarette was smoked out in a new one
had to be lit so I smoked again,
and then suddenly this thought flashed
through my mind.
You must do something about it as much
as with your limited capacities,
it will be impossible to make anything
easier than it has already become.
You must with the same humanitarian
enthusiasm as the others undertake to
make something harder.
This notion pleased me immensely and at
the same time it flattered me to think
that I like the rest of them would be
loved and esteemed by the whole
community,
for when all combined in every way to
make everything easier,
there remains only one possible danger,
namely at the east becomes so great that
it becomes altogether too great.
Then there's only one left though it is
not yet a felt.
Want when people will want difficulty
out of love for mankind and how to
despair it.
My embarrassing situation,
seeing that I had accomplished nothing
and was unable to make anything easier
than it had already been made and moved
by a genuine interest in those who make
everything easy.
I conceived it as my task to create
difficulties everywhere.
Kierkegaard again,
there is a view of life which conceives
that where the crowd is there is also
the truth and that in truth itself,
there is need of having the crowd on its
side.
There's another view of life which
conceives that wherever there is a
crowd,
there is immediately untruth so that to
consider for a moment the example,
even if every individual,
each for himself in private were to be
in possession of the truth.
Yet in the case they were all to get
together in a crowd.
A crowd to which any sort of decisive
significance is attributed to voting,
noisy,
audible crowd untruth would add once be
in evidence for a crowd is the untruth
in a godly sense.
It is true eternally Christianly as St
Paul says,
that only one attains the goal which is
not meant in a comparative sense because
a comparison takes others into account.
It means that every man can be that one
God helping him,
they're in,
but only one attains the goal,
and again,
this means that every band should be
careful about having to do with the
others and essentially should talk only
with God and with himself for only one
attains the goal,
and again this means that man or to be a
man is akin to daddy
in a world in a worldly and temporal
sense.
It will be said by the man of bustle,
sociability and amicable.
Nis,
how unreasonable than only one attains
the goal for it is far more likely that
many by the strength of united effort
should attain the goal and when we are
many success is more certain and it is
easy and it is easier for each man
severally true enough.
It is far more likely
I.
it's true also with respect to all
earthly and material goods.
If it is allowed to have its way,
this becomes the only true point of view
and it does away with God and eternity
and with man's kinship,
with dod.
It does away with it,
transforms it into a fable and puts in
its place the modern or or we might
rather to say the old pagan notion that
to be a man is to belong to a race,
endowed with reason to belong to it as a
specimen so that the race or species is
higher than the individual.
Which is to say that there are no
individuals but only specimens but
eternity which arches over and high
above the temporal tranquil as the story
vault at night and God in heaven.
Who in the bliss of that sublime
tranquility holds in survey without the
least sense of dizziness,
etc. Height those countless multitudes
of men and knows each single individual
by name.
He the great examiner says that only one
attains the goal.
Nisha a similar comment,
the traveler,
a traveler who had seen many countries
and peoples in several continents,
was asked what human traits he had found
everywhere and he answered,
men are inclined to laziness,
some will feel he might've said with
greater justice.
They're all timid.
They hide behind customs and opinions
at bottom.
Every human being knows very well that
he is in this world just once as
something
and that no accident,
however strange we'll throw together a
second time into a unity,
such a curious undiffuse,
plurality.
He knows that,
but he hides it like a bad conscience.
Why?
From fear of his neighbor who insists on
convention and avails himself with it,
but what is it that compels the
individual human being to fear his
neighbor,
to think and act heard fashion and not
to be glad of himself.
A sense of shame.
Perhaps in a few rare cases,
in the vast majority,
it is the desire for comfort,
inertia in short,
that inclination to laziness of which
the traveler spoke.
He is right.
Men are even lazier than they are timid,
and what they fear most is the troubles
with which any unconditional honesty and
nudity with burden them.
Only artists hate this slovenly life and
borrowed manners and loosely fitting or
opinions and unveil the secret.
Everyone's bad conscience.
The principle that every human being is
a unique wonder.
They dare to show us the human being as
he is down to the last muscle himself
and himself alone.
Even more.
That in this rigorous consistency of his
uniqueness,
he is beautiful and worth contemplating
as novel and incredible as every work of
nature and by no means dull.
When a great thinker despises men,
it's their laziness that he despises for
days on account of this,
that they have the appearance of factory
products and seem indifferent and
unworthy of companionship or
instruction.
The human being who does not wish to
belong to the mass must merely cease
being comfortable with himself.
Let Him follow his conscience which
shouts at him.
Be yourself,
what you are at present,
doing,
opining,
and desiring.
That's not really you.
Why are you so firmly and triumphantly
convinced that only the normal and the
positive?
In other words,
only what is conducive to welfare is for
the advantage of man is not reasoning in
error as regards in vantage does not man
perhaps loves something besides
wellbeing.
Perhaps he is just as fond of suffering.
Perhaps suffering is just as great a
benefit to him as well.
Being man is sometimes extraordinarily
passionately in love with suffering and
that is a fact.
There is no need to appeal to universal
history to prove that.
Ask yourself if you're a man and have
lived at all.
As far as my personal opinion is
concerned to care only for wellbeing.
seems to me how positively ill bread,
whether it's good or bad,
it's sometimes very pleasant to to smash
things.
I hold no brooke brief for suffering nor
for wellbeing.
Either I'm standing for my caprice and
for its being guaranteed to me when
necessary suffering would be out of
place.
At amusement parks,
for instance,
I know that
in the palace of crystal,
it is unthinkable now in the late 18
hundreds,
there was a world exhibition in london
and they've corrected a palace of
crystal at the world exhibition and it
was the first building made out of glass
and steel,
and so it was a representation of the
dawning materialist utopia,
and that's the palace of crystal that
dostoevsky is referring to in the palace
of crystal.
Crystal sufferiNg is unthinkable.
Suffering means doubt,
negation,
and what would be the good of a palace
of crystal if there could be any doubt
about it,
and yet I think man will never renounced
real suffering.
That is destruction and chaos.
Why?
Suffering is the sole origin of
consciousness.
Though I did lay it down at the
beginning,
that consciousness is the greatest
misfortune for man,
yet I know man prizes it and would not
give it up for any satisfaction.
We're now in a position to see the
crucial significance of the existential
psychotherapy movement.
It is precisely the movement that
protests against the tendency to
identify psychotherapy with technical
reason.
We have seen that character garden
nature as well as the representatives of
the existential cultural movement
following them.
We have seen that yes,
not only contributed far reaching and
penetrating psychological insights which
in themselves form a significant
contribution to anyone seeking
scientifically to understand modern
psychological problems,
but also did something else.
They placed these insights on an
ontological basis,
namely the study of the individual as
the being who has these particular
problems.
They believed that it was absolutely
necessary that this be done and that
they feared that the subordination of
reason to technical problems would all
to bluntly mean the making of man over
in the image of the machine.
That's it.
We'll see you on thursday.
Thank you.
You're going to have to stop doing that.
Someone accused me of youtube on youtube
of of a dubbing in applause at the end
of my lecturers.